>>> WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
THE UNION."
AS WE HEAD INTO THE HOLIDAYS,
ALL AMERICANS OVER THE AGE OF 18
ARE NOW ELIGIBLE FOR COVID
BOOSTER SHOTS.
THE CDC SAID THAT ON FRIDAY.
THE DECISION COMES AS SOME
HEALTH EXPERTS WARN ABOUT A
POSSIBLE WINTER SURGE.
JOINING ME NOW IS DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, DR. FAUCI, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING ME THIS
MORNING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BOOSTER
SHOT BECAUSE THEY ARE NOW
AUTHORIZED FOR ALL ADULTS.
THE CDC SAYS THOSE OVER 65 OR
WITH UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
SHOULD GET BOOSTERS, BUT FOR
EVERYONE ELSE, IT ONLY SAYS THEY
MAY GET A BOOSTER.
SO CAN YOU CLEAR THIS UP FOR US?
DO YOU RECOMMEND THAT EVERY
SINGLE AMERICAN 18 AND OLDER GET
A BOOSTER SHOT?
>> ABSOLUTELY, DANA.
LET'S MAKE IT CLEAR.
WHEN THERE'S LACK OF CLARITY,
PEOPLE GET CONFUSED.
THEY'RE NOT SURE WHAT TO DO.
IF YOU ARE 18 OR OLDER, AND
YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED, FULLY
VACCINATED WITH THE MODERNA OR
THE PFIZER mRNA, SIX MONTHS OR
MORE AGO, GET A BOOSTER, IF IT'S
J&J, AND IT'S TWO MONTHS AGO, OR
MORE, GET A BOOSTER.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD GET HUNG
UP ON SHOULD/MAY.
JUST GO OUT AND GET BOOSTED.
WE KNOW THEY'RE SAFE AND HE WITH
KNOW THEY'RE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN
BRINGING VERY, HAVE HE HIGH UP
THE OPTIMIZATION OF YOUR
PROTECTION.
SO JUST GO AHEAD AND GET
BOOSTED.
NOW IS THE TIME TO DO IT, AS
WE'RE GETTING INTO THE HOLIDAY
SEASON, YOU WANT TO BE FULLY
PROTECTED IN THE SENSE OF
GETTING OPTIMAL.
THE VACCINES THEMSELVES CLEARLY
ARE STILL HIGHLY EFFECTIVE, BUT
BUT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
DURABILITY OF THE VACCINE IS
LONGER AND THAT'S WHY WE GET
BOOSTERS.
THE PROTECTION STARTS TO WANE A
BIT AND THAT'S WHERE THE
BOOSTERS ARE ALL ABOUT.
BOTTOM LINE, DAMN IT, GET
BOOSTED.
>> THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
TWO MONTHS AGO THE FDA REJECTED
AUTHORIZING BOOSTERS FOR ALL
ADULTS AND FORMER FDA
COMMISSIONER SCOTT GOTTLIEB SAID
THE HANDLING OF BOOSTERS, QUOTE,
MAY END UP BEING ONE OF THE
BIGGEST MISSED OPPORTUNITIES OF
THIS PANDEMIC.
I KNOW YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN PRO
BOOSTER, BUT IS HE RIGHT?
>> IN CERTAIN RESPECTS I THINK
THE LACK OF CLARITY WAS THE
THING THAT GOT PEOPLE CONFUSED
AND THAT'S WHY MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUES ARE VERY PLEASED NOW
WE HAVE CLARITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED.
WE HAVE A VERY POWERFUL TOOL AT
OUR DISPOSAL AND LET'S USE IT
OPTIMALLY AND GET ANY LACK OF
CLARITY OUT OF THE WAY TO DO IT
PROPERLY.
>> YOU SAID HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAD ONLY TWO DOSES
ARE ALREADY PICKING UP.
IS THAT THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES FULLY VACCINATED,
DOES IT NEED TO CHANGE NOW TO
INCLUDE A BOOSTER SHOT?
>> WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THAT
VERY CAREFULLY, DANA.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAY -- AND THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE MEAN WHEN WE SAY
WE NEED TO LET THE SCIENCE
FOLLOW.
AND WE WILL FOLLOW PEOPLE WHO
GET BOOSTED.
WE DON'T KNOW RIGHT NOW.
TO BE PERFECTLY TRANSPARENT, WE
WILL DO THE BEST WE CAN TO KEEP
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OPTIMALLY
PROTECTED.
IF THAT MEANS THAT WILL BE A
BOOST THAT ABSOLUTELY EVERYONE
HAS TO HAVE, SO BE IT, WE'LL DO
IT THAT WAY.
BUT IT WILL BE GUIDED BY THE
SCIENCE.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE PUT OFF BY
THE FACT AS TIME GOES BY AND WE
LEARN MORE AND MORE ABOUT THE
PROTECTION WE MIGHT MODIFY THE
GUIDELINES.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING
ALL ALONG BY FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
THINGS CHANGE AND YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE DATA.
>> WHICH I UNDERSTAND BUT GIVEN
THE FACT YOU'RE SAYING PLEASE
GET BOOSTERS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED, IF BEFORE WE GET
BOOSTERRED.
AT THIS POINT GIVEN WHAT YOU
KNOW, ACCURATE TO SAY TWO SHOTS
DOESN'T MEAN FULLY VACCINATED
ANYWHERE?
>> TWO SHOTS FOR A TIME FRAME
MEANS YOU'RE FULLY VACCINATED.
BUT THE THING YOU WANT TO GET
THE PEOPLE AND THE VIEWERS TO
UNDERSTAND, IT ISN'T JUST THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE VACCINE
THAT'S QUITE EFFECTIVE, IT'S HOW
LONG IT LASTS AND THAT'S THE
REASON WE STARTED TO SEE THE
IMMUNITY START TO WANE, WE SAID
PEOPLE SHOULD BE BOOSTERED.
AND THAT'S WHY WE WILL KEEP
FOLLOWING CLOSELY.
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> GOT IT.
IN EUROPE THEY'RE DEALING WITH A
CRIPPLING NEW RISE OF INFECTIONS
AND IN THE U.S. INFECTIONS ARE
RISING FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
WEEKS AND AVERAGING 100,000 NEW
CASES PER DAY.
ARE WE BEGINNING TO SEE A WINTER
WAVE?
>> CERTAINLY, YOU CAN'T WALK
AWAY FROM THE DATA AND THE DATA
SHOWS THAT THE CASES ARE
STARTING TO GO UP, WHICH IS NOT
UNEXPECTED WHEN YOU GET INTO A
WINTER SEASON AND YOU KNOW
IMMUNITY DOES WANE OVER TIME AND
YOU LOOK AND SAY WHAT CAN WE DO
ABOUT THAT AND YOU STILL HAVE
ABOUT 60 MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
VACCINATED.
AND THAT RESULTS IN THE DYNAMIC
OF VIRUS IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
NOT ONLY IS DANGEROUS AND MAKES
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNVACCINATED
VULNERABLE, BUT IT ALSO SPILLS
OVER INTO THE VACCINATED PEOPLE
BECAUSE NO VACCINE IS 100%
EFFECTIVE, AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
VIRUS CIRCULATING AROUND.
WE KNOW THERE ARE BREAKTHROUGH
INFECTIONS AND THAT'S HOW YOU
GET THE UPTICK IN CASES.
THE BOTTOM LINE COMMON
DENOMINATOR OF ALL OF THIS,
DANA, IS GET VACCINATED IF YOU
HAVE NOT BEEN VACCINATED AND
BOOSTERED IF YOU HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
HOLIDAYS.
A POLL FOUND TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICANS SAY THEIR THANKSGIVING
GATHERING WILL GO BACK TO THE
SIZE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
WITH THAT IN MIND, WHAT ARE YOUR
RECOMMEND,S FOR AMERICANS TO
CELEBRATE SAFELY?
>> MY RECOMMENDATIONS TO
AMERICANS TO CELEBRATE SAFELY IS
GET VACCINATED AS SOON AS YOU
CAN.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE NOT
VACCINATED, YOU'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE MORE
VULNERABLE TO GETTING INFECTED
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED, PEOPLE WHO CAN GET
BOOSTERED, ENJOY YOUR HOLIDAY
SEASON WITH YOUR FAMILY, DO IT.
BUT BE AWARE WHEN YOU'RE IN A
SITUATION WHEN YOU'RE TRAVELING,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN AN INDOOR
CONGREGATE SETTING AND YOU DON'T
KNOW THE VACCINATION STATUS OF
PEOPLE, YOU NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
BUT IN FAMILY SETTINGS,
PARTICULARLY AMONG VACCINATED
PEOPLE, ENJOY THE HOLIDAY.
THAT'S THANKSGIVING.
LOOKING AHEAD TO CHRISTMAS,
RIGHT NOW SINCE WE CAN VACCINE
CHILDREN FROM 5 TO 11, YOU START
VACCINATING THEM NOW, THEY WILL
BE FULLY VACCINATED BY THE TIME
WE GET TO THE CHRISTMAS HOLIDAYS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT.
>> I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
SOMETHING YOU SAID AND MAKE SURE
OUR VIEWERS ARE CLEAR ON IT.
IF YOU'RE VACCINATED AND YOU'RE
GOING TO A HOLIDAY SETTING WHERE
EVERYBODY IS VACCINATED, IT'S
OKAY TO BE THERE WITHOUT A MASK?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO DO WITH
MY FAMILY AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK PEOPLE SHOULD DO.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT WE KEEP
GETTING BACK TO, THAT IS THE
SAFETY NET, VACCINATION.
TAKE AWAY THE ANXIETY AND TAKE
AWAY THE CONCERN ABOUT WHAT YOU
SHOULD DO AND NOT, AND YOU CAN
ENJOY THE HOLIDAYS SAFELY.
IF NOT, GET TESTED WHEN YOU GET
TOGETHER.
BUT THAT'S NOT A SUBSTITUTE FOR
GETTING VACCINATED.
GET YOURSELF VACCINATED SO YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO ENJOY
INTERACTIONS WITH YO